un air de déjà vu ce rond-point comme ce
que les gilets jaunes ont régulièrement
occupé un peu partout en france au plus
fort de leur contestation revis sauf que
c'est de la fiction
tout a été recréé le temps d'un tournage
inspiré de ce mouvement qui a secoué le
pays il est quelques années
là il faut deux figures de proue ainsi
la voiture de police ici un court
métrage plutôt qu'un documentaire
mouvement des jeunes y sent un peu perdu
du coup faire un documentaire autour du
sort c'est un peu autre chose il n'y
avait qu'à voir la faible mobilisation
lors d'une récente manifestation dans
cette ville amiens l'une des plus
pauvres de france frappée par des
délocalisations et des fermetures
d'usinés cette ville où les gilet jaune
ont combattu emmanuel macron dans la rue
ça symbolise plein de choses voilà voit
recevoir le président qui venait ici
avec le gilet jaune sur lui avec le
loyer bordier
comme d'autres il a sur le coeur
l'utilisation de projectiles en
caoutchouc par les forces de l'ordre les
blocages et les manifestations au départ
pacifique ont souvent été émaillées de
violences de part et d'autre
il attribue à la répression et aux
arrestations une partie de
l'essoufflement du mouvement qui s'était
voulue à politique avec des porte parole
mais sans têtes dirigeantes on n'est pas
structurée n'est pas aidé on n'a pas de
fric on n'a pas des secrétaires d'état
n'a pas des mêmes des secrétaires des
gens qui gèrent pour nous on fait ça à
l'arraché avec des bouts de carton aura
pas de d'armure n'a pas d'armée l'ont
fait en fait que des bouts de moyens
avec le temps qu'on peu à côté de nos
métiers à côté de nos vies à côté de nos
enfants à côté de nos passions on met
tous un peu de côté aussi un moment
donné et quant au soir du 10 avril
emmanuel macron s'est qualifié pour le
deuxième tour j'ai pleuré
mais j'ai pleuré
sincèrement pleurer
parce que ça fait quatre ans que je suis
dans la rue près gilet jaune après avoir
reculé sur une nouvelle taxe sur
l'essence l'origine de la colère en 2018
et du mouvement emmanuel macron on a
acquiescé qu'à quelques autres
revendications des gilets jaunes par
exemple une prestation sociale
supplémentaire
l on va dire on nous a balancé une
cacahuète on a quand même eu sein et je
sais qu'il ya des gens pour qui ça
vraiment été bénéfique et durant
lendemain ils ont touché 100 150 euros
en plus
pour nous c'est beaucoup pour eux c'est
rien tous deux ne peuvent se résoudre à
voter soit pour le président sortant ou
la candidate du rassemblement national
le 24 avril bien que 40% des gilets
jaunes auraient voté pour marine le pen
au premier tour sensible à plusieurs de
ces arguments notamment contre les
mesures anti qu'ovide cette femme qui
fut l'une des figures de proue du
mouvement va d'ailleurs le faire
dimanche je regrette terriblement de
voir des copains gilet jaune
appeler clairement
je comprends le côté cottereau macron
mais appelé clairement à voter marine le
pen parce qu'on n'aura rien mieux avec
ça avec ce parti dont ils comptent
s'abstenir ou deuxième tours comme bien
d'autres plus question de participer un
front républicain contre marine le pen
comme en 2017 ou contre son père il ya
quasiment 20 ans et pas question d'être
tenu pour responsable si jamais
l'abstention devait favoriser l'entraidé
l'extrême droite à l'elysée j'ai passé
80 battre contre le gouvernement macron
c'est toute ma vie je me suis battu
contre le front national moi j'ai fait
d'autres choix donc maintenant les gens
qui ont fait le choix macron le pen
c'est à eux de prendre leurs
responsabilités et au gilet jaune à
réfléchir à la mobilisation lors du
prochain quinquennat ici annick bureaud
radio-canada amiens